il faudra bientôt montrer patte blanche
pour adopter détenir un animal les
futurs adoptants pourrait ne plus
trouver leur chien ou leur chat dans des
animaleries avec la loi sur la
maltraitance animale les amoureux des
bêtes devront notamment obtenir un
certificat de connaissances celui qui
devient propriétaire saura à quoi il
s'engage stora ce qu'on attend de lui et
ça lui permettra d'être mieux éclairer
sur son choix parce qu'on peut avoir
envie d'un chien mais peut-être que
c'est pas la bonne catégorie 2 chiens la
bonne taille parce que telle ou telle
espèce requiert plus d'attention et peut
être aussi plus de soins vétérinaires à
terme des sanctions plus lourdes en cas
de maltraitance qu'elle soit volontaire
ou liées à la méconnaissance de l'animal
les peines encourues vont de 1 à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement l'amande peut monter
jusqu'à soixante quinze mille euros
parmi les autres articles de la loi
l'interdiction progressive d'animaux
sauvages dans les cirques et les
élevages de visons pour leur fourrure
ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui ce qui
n'existe pas en france mais je préfère
qu'on pose des garde-fous c'est qu'on
élargisse cette interdiction à
l'ensemble des animaux sauvages de
manière à ce qu'on n'est pas demain
l'idée de quelqu'un d'ouvrir un élevage
de fourrure de renard par exemple un
texte attendu par les associations à
bazoches sur guyonne la fondation
brigitte bardot accueille plusieurs
centaines de compagnons à quatre pattes
chats chiens et animaux de ferme
c'est très important de voir qu'il ya
enfin une réponse politique à la tante
sociétale nous ça fait des décennies
maintenant qu'on travaille avec les
politiques successifs sans obtenir aucun
résultat alors cette proposition de loi
elle ne répond pas à toutes nos attentes
bien évidemment il ya des sujets comme
la chasse l'élevage intensif la corrida
et d'autres qui ne sont pas abordées
mais ça amorce un changement et ça c'est
véritablement nouveau elle la loi doit
être examiné à l'assemblée nationale
jusqu'au 29 janvier
la france compte 63 millions d'animaux
de compagnie